critics and viewers agree Paul Dano's
Master Riddler and the Batman is
terrifying so why are fans cracking up
over one of his scenes keep watching to
find out heads up spoilers ahead Matt
Reeves of Batman offers up one of the
most realistic and frightening takes on
a DC Comics villain to date with the
Riddler giving off Vibes that are deeply
reminiscent of the Zodiac Killer you
know it's like okay that's like a much
more sort of real right
yes but not everything about the
brilliant and terrifying character as a
Hollywood Reporter describes him is
scary on the surface in fact there's one
unintentionally funny scene involving
the Riddler that comes toward the end of
the Batman that has many fans laughing
the more they think about it a
surprisingly comical Riddler scene is
found in the third and final Act of the
Warner Brothers flick Thanos Riddler is
seen attempting to Rally online
supporters in an effort to bring chaos
and violence to Gotham but what he
really comes off as is just some dorky
dream a guy as fans put it on Reddit I
just sorted a slice of pumpkin pie
in a moment where fiction comes
hilariously close to reality a team of
Gotham City police officers and Batman
discover a dark web social media profile
where they learn Riddler's been posting
regular updates to his 500 plus
followers it would appear that the main
antagonist of the Batman is interacting
online with supporters as if he's an
Instagram or YouTube influencer he
addresses them by saying hey guys
welcome back to my channel the video has
racked up tons of heart emojis or likes
from followers who also contribute
comments to show their allegiance the
video shows Riddler going so far as to
thank his growing brood for quote liking
commenting and subscribing to his
channel while also showing his
appreciation for some advice that people
gave him regarding bomb detonators
the Batman fans took to a Reddit pose to
discuss this particular scene pointing
out how the third act revealed risks
neutralizing any threatening energy
Riddler gives off earlier in the movie
One redditor wrote I love how he does
the creepy zodiac thing for the police
and the media but then that last video
for his followers was one of those dorky
hey guys thanks for the comments like
and Subscribe videos like every random
YouTuber another Reddit user replied
that's like hard to me was so funny
without it feeling telegraphed or forced
both of the redditors comments received
more than 2 000 of votes combined what
ultimately makes a scene hilarious for
moviegoers is the juxtaposition of
Dano's wild and chaotic Master Riddler
with his quiet side which conjures up
comparisons to the in-cell community and
so Reddit has put it still while a lot
of film goers were laughing at the scene
many were also deeply disturbed by it
and other Clips at the Riddler released
throughout the movie One reddit's user
admitted it felt so unnerving and
chilling to watch how Riddler can be
this devious yet calculated serial
killer one moment to this dorky streamer
guy another person agreed saying legit
Paul had to steal your killer slash
incel school shooter Persona down so
well it was both uncanny and supremely
entertaining a third user chimed in
adding it was even the same with his
face to face with the Batman you see him
just doing about phase from calculated
sociopath to Crazy manic on a dime
multiple times it was a little bit
unsettling according to collider Matt
Reeves Riddler was ultimately inspired
by the director's fascination with the
Zodiac Killer which grew after reading
the 1995 nonfiction book mindhunter
inside the FBI's Elite serial crime unit
the book later inspired a Netflix show
of the same name what a lot of
moviegoers might not know is that Reeves
also intended for his Riddler to be a
mass killer terrorist of sorts as seen
when he attacks the Gotham City Funeral
using a car and unwilling victim as a
driver Reeves told total film he's not
just a serial killer he definitely has a
political agenda there's a terrorist
aspect to him The Riddles were both uh
fun but also emotional and they they are
layered themselves check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
Looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one